[Music]
hello good morning I'm very glad to be
here to talk about our journey in
building a distributed data access layer
for a lot of different analytics and
machine learning workloads little bit
about me my name's Ben and I am founding
engineer in the Alexia company and I'm
also the PMC member for the open source
project a Luxio so before I joined the
Luxio I work in Google to work on the
next generation large-scale storage
system and before I joined Google I
worked I was a PhD student in Carnegie
Mellon working on networking and
distributed storage systems ok so we
will share some insights from the team a
Luxio how we view the world it's going
the data world is going so essentially
we see the journey to a more fragmented
data world in in today so we see first
of all there there's just more and more
data generated every day according to
latest statics we see every day there
are more than 2.5 a bead data generated
and with all this amount of data is
generated it's natural to ask like what
are this data and how we going to do
with this data were to store this data
and also in the near future you can see
as the more popularity of 5g technology
or the a IOT technology and even
blockchain technology people are just
going to generating more and more data
so this will be more of a severe problem
the first problem is how with a lot of
this data how we can consume them how we
can consume data in the efficient way to
derive insights derive value from the
data there will be more people they need
the data from that they need more
insight and different values from data
and also different data products to be
derived from the data and next we see is
in the net every three to eight years
there will be a new technology emerging
or new sets of technology emerging about
new ways to store data new way to
provide data and also it comes
comes with the hardware change hardware
improvement or even just like at the new
algorithms new ways to architect
software's or distribute file systems
yeah so we see different chance deriving
a new architecture in this world
the first way the first way we see in
the field is really a separation compute
and storage actually a lot of companies
they are already on the track they see
in the past a few years in a past decade
people are talking about oh we have a
couple compute and storage it provides a
great performance because the can we
move computer data so we can save the
network a cost and we can make the
MapReduce really fast however nowadays
if you go to this lot of companies they
are either either telling you oh we're
separating our compute server pause with
this story to pause the reason is they
have different characteristics or they
scale the one scale in different
dimensions one is on CPU on the resource
computation resource one is on the
storage and in the other reason is all
the popul popular for example
containerization orchestration
frameworks emerging like kubernetes
people want to go with Moore's Elastic
Compute but less so for the storage
sites they have very different
characteristics in nature so people are
doing this separation for computing and
storage and next trend we see is the
hybrid and multi-core environment so if
you talk to companies founded maybe in
the past of five years a lot of them are
born on the cloud like our company we
don't have a single box at all in our
office or any data warehouse every all
the infrastructure is built on a SS or
similar public cloud vendors and moving
to the cloud is - it's just like a it's
a take its ground it's taken for ground
it's for a lot of new companies and even
for the legacy company or a little older
companies they are already aggressively
looking at their cloud strategy how they
can use the average public compute part
public cloud resource in a cloud vendors
or these do you have their they want to
maintain their own on-demand or in their
data warehouse their resource but how we
can combine all the resource together to
have more efficient architecture and the
search rent is we see a lot the rise of
the object store a lot of people are
saying oh yeah in early days we were
told HDFS is very cheap it's the most
achieve that cheap is the way to save a
lot of bytes Knossos not quite so
actually in reality it takes a lot of
money and human resource actually and
DevOps
resource to maintain out bytes on your
HDFS so since moving to h2 object or is
easier to maintain and also it's easier
it's cheaper for a lot of different
companies a third one is is the fourth
one is we see a lot of because there's
there's a lot of companies they have a
lot of different data sources differ
data silos so they just nowadays realize
okay there are new ways to generate
value from all different power of data
so how can I do this how can I do a data
analytics effectively across different
data sources so all these are the trends
we see in the fields in the pasture
especially in the Fastpass of one or two
years so if you see this is the lot of
the common architecture ten years ago
people are talking about MapReduce
co-located with HDFS and this is a great
big house it follows the paper published
by Google fifteen years ago it's talking
about data locality great but however if
you go to the data ecosystem nowadays
you see more and more different ways to
process data more specialized frameworks
doing graph processing doing streaming
doing deep learning or machine learning
workloads and also you have all
different choices on your storage like
s3 is definitely one of the most popular
and very popular were in the last few
years and also all the storage vendors
that you had to come up with their own
devices saying okay this is compatible
with this big data analytics
and just plug it okay so we see a lot of
these trends so people started from the
co-located HDFS with their computer like
a MapReduce typify depay MapReduce or
hive workloads then they go to more
modern waves saying okay
I want to separate my compute and HDFS a
little bit in the same data center I
know like a lot of infrastructure
engineers actually are working on this
in different companies to separate this
and and now they are talking about more
oh how I can burst my work clothes into
cloud public cloud or private cloud or
how I can support more frameworks I want
to share my data between presto and hive
or spark and hive because they are
representing different analytics
workloads or I have my data actually
used even across different teams and
attics team and machine learning teams
how I can support data sharing without
any application or the source code
change and in the end how we can enable
accelerate big data workloads object
Wars of just always great it's cheap but
it's not that performs if you just use
them like plug and play in a way so
associate with this transition we do see
a lot of different challenges one is how
we can use HDFS well in a hybrid cloud
and if you just directly read data from
HDFS it typically can be over do over
over the network a public network it can
be very slow or expensive and also
copying data like doing the typical ETL
traditional ETL can be less efficient
and usually they designed his team they
don't want to involve their ETL team
because that can be very a long process
to wait and also using HDFS the HDFS has
a connector to talk to s3 that this kind
of a public cloud when storage but this
is not typically not optimized for big
data workloads people are working on
that like um
spark on hive MapReduce community they
are working on that but still
fundamentally object stores like s3 is
not file system it has a lot of
different design trade-offs there
so this has implications in security in
consistency and in performance to big
data analytics workloads also how can we
support more workloads more
frameworks copying data from one place
to another can be imagined can be very
slow and expensive and migrating
applications can be hard to maintain
hard to manage and also how do we
translate too obvious or it's not
trivial at all it turns out a lot of
people hit see a lot of performance hits
when they just put up your store there
so this is a big challenge for a lot of
companies we see in the in the past few
years so what we're doing here actually
we're saying hmm maybe it's time because
the ecosystem is getting too complicated
let's simplify it a little bit how can
we do this simplification we add another
layer you know like in the past 60 years
there is no real advance in the computer
science at all but just adding more
interactions adding more caching these
are the two like commonly used
technology techniques again again in
different contexts
and here which thing maybe it's a time
we can do a data oxidation layer for the
cloud so what we mean here is we want to
provide a layer and this layer is not
responsible for data reliable storing
data reliably so that's the job for the
storage system ss3 or it's HDFS or it's
your favorite vendor storage but that's
not the job for this detox attrition so
what this data oxidation layer is doing
is to provide really accessibility so
different applications can use different
API Zorin same set of API to access the
same set of data and also elasticity so
compute nowadays people are making
compute more and more elastic but how we
can make data as elastic as compute
because if you want data to be the
persistent data storage layer it's very
hard to be elastic you have to be
there's a lot of limitation a lot of
restriction but once you get rid of this
assumption we'd need to be reliable data
but just for compute the computation or
data there
you can do a lot of smart things for
example for the hot data you can make
more repetitions and for the code data
because the reliability is handled by
storage let's just evict them off so
this can do the caching layer and also
can do more like data transition from
one form to another based on the life
cycle of the data so these are the layer
where imagine we're thinking can be very
useful to the ecosystem to the data
ecosystem in the new era so I'm talking
about like a few cases and in here
because a Luxio is the open source
project we built as one for example one
implementation for this for this data a
new action a new data arc situation
layer so what we do here is we show a
different new use cases we enable two in
the data use ism the first one is this
accelerated data frame works on public
cloud so for a lot of startups for a lot
of like a midsize the companies we see
architectures like this they build
everything on AWS or egg or a juror and
the use EMR or use they're just Apache
versions of these analytics and using s3
as the single source of choose which is
great this simplifies architecture a lot
so one issue they commonly a complaint
is about the performance writing to s3
is often a very painful process
especially given all this if you have a
scientific or machine learning like
workloads you have to write this to a
stream repeatedly and also reading data
from s3 it really depends on the luck I
have some demos to show but I don't
think I have time for this session I can
do that in the office hour so s3
performance read performance is really
has a lot of variance so what we provide
here is if you add a Luxio co-located
with your spark war clothes and which is
connecting to s3 and then in this case
we provide benefits like a caching data
caching the hard data into the workloads
so this will get performance very stable
but also very good the next case we're
saying this new architecture enables is
for example you have the on premise
Senta you have a data there because you
are a you are a hedge fund your data is
your life you don't want to really put
your data in any form of public cloud
and also there is regulation so but you
really like the resource elastics it the
elasticity aspect of the public cloud so
when you train the models when you run
big data workloads you say okay if I'm
waiting in my promise data center I need
for another five days to get my resource
to run my machine learning workloads to
trim my models but if I just leverage
public clouds I can just click the
button and get 200 ec2 machines and I
can start my machine learning training
processes right away the problem is
moving data and no one wants to do this
so if you have this data orchestration
layer in the cloud to help that move the
data to where it is needed and really
also replicate the data if the data is
more needed and then this will simplify
the life for a lot of data scientists a
lot and the last one is really how do
you use similar objects or to replace
your for example previous HDFS the for
budgets for forecast the saving per and
in this case you can put this data
actuation layered there to co-locate
waste workloads and get still get same
or even better performance and there are
some advanced the more more advanced
that use cases for example enabling
talking to across different single cloud
or multiple different clouds building a
data up abstraction layer or having data
on a public cloud and using this to
share data across different workloads
like a Presta workloads or smark
workloads yeah so the key innovation we
provided we are providing here is we
built a data look how we try to bridge
data locality by building a caching
smart caching inside that does the dis
layers so we can do intelligent
monitoring caching and we also do that
it accessibility by providing the most
popular API is two different frameworks
and in the end we also
we can merge or we can manage multiple
different storage systems into a single
file system namespace in this way this
becomes the data is really becomes
abstraction to applications to data
scientists rather than the concrete
storage systems I will have more more
more concrete examples of that so this
is how we do the data to improve data
locality so if the data is some data is
hot and then we were a Luxio as a word
one example of the data actuation layer
will just cache this hard data closer to
the computation and in this way you
don't need if if you access the data
they the access pattern is accessing
data repeatedly then you don't need to
always go to the same data source to
read read the data and this will be much
closer hopefully on the same because we
leverage the data locality to expose
data locality to schedulers SPARC
schedulers or MapReduce schedulers
hopefully it will not even use network
to transfer data and on the right side a
a layer like this can also serve as a
write buffer a digital write buffer and
you can write your data to this layer
and we can sing asynchronously propagate
this data to for example the configure
configuration your configured under
storage like s3 or HDFS and and also we
see is we provide this layer like us we
provide different API is popular API is
like HDFS so if you use your
applications is using HDFS API talking
to the data then no code hinge required
it just like configuration change or you
are our change you can directly talk to
s3 or different version of HDFS or Swift
or some other like Hitachi storage and
in this way this transition or this this
this this is automatic and this is also
transparent to the applications and what
we see interesting is in the last few
years we do see more and more
applications on boot directly on top of
s3 api's so either because although all
the new storage they are providing s3
api's compatible ap is or because more
applications are put into the cloud and
using s3 so we do see
s3 is becoming more popular much more
popular in the in the near term and the
other advantage to here is we provide
this namespace management just like you
are doing your mount on your local
machine you can put a hard disk on your
local machine local Mac MacBook or put a
USB heat there and from users
perspective you only see one single
files is the namespace and we do this
exactly the same thing to different
storage systems distributed storage and
its services or endpoints so in this
case you can mount a s3 bucket into a
Luxio namespace and you can also mount
HDFS and to a same flex your namespace
and in the middle of the blue namespace
is the lot basically it's a logical view
for the data and applications or data
scientists they don't need to really
care about of each version of HDFS which
library I need to use and how do I
manage my credentials for s3 and you
just go to and access this logic
filesystem that's it it simply it can
simplify the development and the
management and also maintenance for the
data team a lot so yeah so if we go
further you can also use our tool we
provided to even mount a Luxio service
endpoint into your local mac book using
the POSIX API so Alexia well serves us
just like a folder on your macbook and
even inside this folder there how there
will be subfolders and they will be
backed by other storage services but for
data scientists this can be very easy
because of the new it first because the
legacy were closed they typically
assumed this is past interface or for
the new AI were closed typically a lot
of times people people just they like to
deal with local file folder yeah so this
is the view we see in the in the future
you may have different data sources they
may live in HDFS or different HDFS can
be different versions in different
regions you may have some legacy storage
capacity from an NFS and you may also
you want to leverage a lot by the cloud
storage resources I guess
and you are running different workloads
hives spark or tensorflow and even for
the same spark workloads you have some
undermount resource but sometimes you
want to burst your workload into the
cloud so our vision is once you have
this data orchestration layer the
management and also the data migration
part is totally transparent to the
applications and as application
developers you just need to worry about
just need to know about the data the
logical data path and other than that
the data extrusion layer will just take
care of this yeah so because I'm now
using my own laptops so I will leave my
demos in the office hour which is right
after lunch and I will do how I'll do a
demo to show how can run spark over a
Luxio and mounted by actually mounted by
with two different buckets one rs3 when
you're and from the spark perspective
it's totally the same it's just like a
different folders in the same file
system and also I will run some TPC des
benchmark to show the performance
benefits if you run spark on s3 versus a
spark um allows us three and see how
much benefit you can get by having data
cache the co-located with the compute
side so there's some more details
related to how you can use up like a
layer like this for example on a spark
site all you need to change is to change
the foul if you uh if you if you work
with spark you may know this is the most
useful most common way to deal with the
RTD right into the text file and
typically this is the HDFS URL and now
you just change HDFS into a Luxio
that's it for Hadoop because we are
providing a hadoop really HDFS
compatible API you just do the Hadoop FS
- cat and do the POSIX you can just
simply us do it using the local command
to do the filesystem file system browser
and doing like catch some foul and we
also provide our own Java API so you can
just deal with the Java API together
most handle and most control on the data
and this is their architecture for
example we have it's a similar it's a
similar to a hdfs we have the master
node which is handling the meditative
service and you can use different
mounted master nodes and use zookeeper
our raft to coordinate masters to
guarantee high availability and also we
have workers and different workers can
be luxury workers can co-located with
presto or spark in this way you get
above performance benefits and the
unique thing about this architecture is
we have the under store concept so the
workers and the masters can be backed by
different persistent storage like object
store or the HDFS and you can mount them
together into a same namespace yeah so
because we are adding a new layer so
enables a lot of interesting thing so
first thing is the read different read
mode originally you just read from data
source right but now you have more
different ways you can either read from
the data directly or you can read if the
data is already cached in this layer
then read from this cache layer and get
a performance benefit or even it's in
the same layer in the cache layer but
it's on a remote node that's still
possible to read and still benefit from
that and you saw you can also specify I
won't read this this data but bypassing
the caching I know I only need today's
once I don't really need it twice and no
need to cache there's also flock to do
so on the right side is even more
different choices you can decide I won't
write to this layer only or I want to
write to the persistent storage only or
you can write both because you need to
read it back sometime later and you want
this right happens synchronously or you
can write to the layer first and then
asynchronously this layer will propagate
the data to allow attitude under storage
or you can stat okay I want more
replications I do more replication
control for the data in this layer so I
can write to n different copies and
different workers or you can see I won't
write a lock seal and then
asynchronously how me propagate this
data into different and persistent
storage like hs3 or
to have that data mirror this is some
animation to show how you read you can
read this from this if data is already
cached in a Luxio space or if the data
is reading and it is not really already
cached in a log seal and then you can
read from the Ender store directly on
the right path you can write this data
into Luxio space only so you just go to
the master first master tells you okay
this is the worker close to you right to
this worker and the client application
just write this data to the worker the
same note or you can write data
synchronously to both the persistent
storage or the the Al Aqsa worker and
you can also because we have the new
concept of new layer added there will be
new concept to related to TTL or pinging
you can say I want this data pinging in
this layer for maybe one day or a week
and you can also prefetch data or you
know that there is no more needles you
can just free the data but the data is
no longer is this wall still live in the
persistent storage or you can even doing
data migration across different among
points to my creates data from one and a
sewer to another and we will help you to
do that so one I will just show two use
cases about this use case one is a use
case in China Unicom and this is the one
of the biggest telecom company in China
serving to 320 million user subscribers
in China so they are running spark
workloads on both on different clusters
some are HDFS and some is using object
or our HBase and previously they were
doing the ETL to migrate data from one
place to their HDFS to be consumed by
spark so later on they just decided to
put one oxidation layer here so the
spark for the spark job it's just very
simple I just see all different parts as
different directories I can just use
this directory to access data directly
and this this layer will help me to
migrate data to ETL data and also doing
a caching and this turns out very useful
for them to improve the performance by
they have some benchmark to see five to
ten decks another is they about elastic
and machine learning process so this is
the hatch found in in wall street what
they do is they have their data in there
on premise data warehouse and they want
to use cloud the resource in the cloud
dude burst burst the workloads so what
they do is they turns out they use spark
in public cloud and use this data
orchestration layer co-located with a
spark and once they need to launch the
spark job
they were just used they were pretty low
data into this orchestration either
preload or you loaded an undermount and
use this to replicate data to replicate
to manage the input data replication
distribution and this will greatly
improve their performance they are there
their model development performance and
and they see previously they need to
wait for multiple days before they get
all the resource begin to begin their
model processing model training process
but now because they can leverage the
cloud resource more efficiently we can
start this process much faster and and
get this performance get this end-to-end
model training process much much more
efficient ok so now a lot of enterprises
are moving to the this independent a
cloud and storage and these are actually
a lot of users we are because this is
open source technology so a lot of a lot
of people a lot of complaints they are
leveraging this technology to power
these their internal data infrastructure
and this is a list of a subset of them
ok so I think this is the my last this
is this is the last slide I'm I'm
willing to take some questions or you
can talk to me offline in the office
hour yeah I was wondering if you
actually have any stats on
improvements you know with using it
looks here yes we do have a there's a
lot of articles or blogs online I can
send you some some points later let's
maybe exchange emails offline but yeah
there are there are some articles
talking about their performance gained
to be to be clear it really depends on
the environment and also like how far
your data is and also how slow you
consume your your current IO processing
is but we do see the further the IO is
from the compute the better performance
benefit you get yeah there's one more
question how you handle the encryptions
yeah so we do have a very interesting
because for a lot of there are some
right so there's a some regulation in
different countries about the data
encrypted like what kind of data you can
put in in two different different
continents and we do see cases like for
example at Berkeley they need to make
sure the data is encrypted and also the
data is only in memory to be compliant
with the regulation and they use for
example companies like this they use
allows you to put their data is
encrypted in the persistent storage and
even encrypt it when it's cached in this
layer but it's owning get decrypted when
the client or the application which the
client is reading the data and they will
get a keys and do the decryption and
yeah so this is basically the on high
level how the encryption decryption
story works with us yeah how do you
handle failures this looks like a
distributed database to me it's not a
digital database actually it's a file
system or a storage system because we
don't do with the schemas or for example
the Seco queries it is a Fauss and
objects but failures yeah that's a very
important question so there are
different parts for the metadata part we
use our we have
component called master to handle the
meditated requests and the merited
requests there we you can install
multiple masters so even one master is
down because we are running either
zookeeper or using raft it according in
the different masters so there will be
standby master to take over the
responsibility yeah so on that's the on
the mandated part that's critical and we
try to really try to avoid a single
point of failure on the workers side
which is really the different servers
serving the data a data is chopped in
two different different blocks and
spread across different workers there
are different ways first because we
simplify the concept we're not dealing
with the data persistency or reliability
so even the data is lost if the data has
one copy or has its persistency in the
entire storage system for persistent
storage system we can always fetch it
back and and this process is transparent
it just like you hit some performance a
little bit code on a code code reads and
also there is other cases if you won't
really make sure the data is has high
availability in unlocks you you can
explicitly said I want more replications
of this data and we will just make this
replication for you
[Music]